So there are lots of different ways we could define "bigger."
Here's one possibility:
We're going to make a procedure; we'll give it the name, "bigger".
It takes 2 inputs.
We can give them any name we want.
Since there's no real meaning to the inputs, we'll just use "a" and "b".
And now we want to use a test to figure out which one is bigger.
We're going to use a comparison, so we're going to see if "a" is greater than "b".
Then we want the result to be the value of "a"--that's the bigger one.
So we'll return "a".
If that's not the case--well, if it was the case, we returned "a";
if it's not the case, then we're going to get here, and we can return "b".
So this way of defining "bigger" is a little bit asymmetrical.
Given what you've seen so far, this is probably the best way to do it.
There's another way to do that, that uses an extra construct
that allows us to have 2 directions that we can use the "if" in.
So instead of just having what we had before,
where we have an "if" and we have a test expression,
and we have a block that executes when the test expression is True,
what we want to do is have something that executes when the test expression is False.
And we can do that by using an "else".
We can have--after the "if", instead of the next statement,
we can have an "else" that's part of the "if".
This means if the test expression was True,
we're going to execute this block.
If it's not True, we're going to execute the other block,
which is inside the "else".
As before, the indentation tells us when we're done with the block,
so after the "else", whatever code is here
will execute whether the test expression is True or False.
The test expression determines whether we execute
the block inside the "if" or the block inside the "else".
So let's see how to rewrite "bigger" using "else".
We'll use "a" and "b" as the names of our parameters, as before,
and we'll start the same--we're going to have our "if"
and our test is still "a > b",
and if that's the case, then we return "a".
Instead of having the next statement return "b",
we're going to think about having an "else" clause
that says: well, if "a" was not greater than "b", what shall we do?
If "a" is not greater than "b", then "b" is either the same size or bigger,
and what we want to do is return "b".
So this means the same thing.
In this case, neither one is particularly better.
I think this one is a little more symmetrical.
There are lots of cases where it makes things work a lot better by using "else".
And I'll show you one way that this could be different.
If we didn't want to have two returns--
maybe we'll want to do something else with the result, instead of just return it--
well, with the "if, else" we can do that.
So we can have--inside the first "if", we'll assign to the variable "r" the result "a".
That's going to be the one that's bigger.
Inside the "else", we'll assign to the variable "r" the result "b".
That's the one that's bigger when the "if" test fails.
And now the next statement here could return "r".
Usually, we like our programs to be shorter
rather than bigger.
In this case, when we're defining "bigger",
maybe the "bigger" version is better because that's a little easier to understand and follow.